[Applaudissements]
mon travail c'est de comprendre et de
soigner les bouffées de chaleur les
roosli gastrique générés par un
nervosité impactant sur le larynx à
cause d'une dilatation des muqueuses et
du corps spongieux et en d'autres termes
la notation est une drogue nerb allez
monsieur on reprend ce la dernière
tentative après celle opération alors
vous visualisez vos cordes vocales à la
respirer maintenant imaginez celle de
barry white et aux lilas
[Musique]
j'ai mal à ma gauche et mal à ma gorge
j'ai mal à ma gauche et la gorge c'est
la vie la vie c'est la voie la parole
c'est la vie je pousse un coup de gueule
contre magor parce qu elle m'empêche
d'être libre et la liberté c'est la
qualité intrinsèque de l'homme et nerb
c'est inadmissible c'est ici
[Applaudissements]